well the March for science was over the
weekend organized sort of the main March
in Washington DC there were marches all
over the country all over the world
actually reportedly 600 satellite
marches coinciding with Earth Day and
there was a big March here in Boston
there was a big one in Los Angeles San
Francisco New York Chicago our producer
Noah Ferguson actually attended the DC
March and took a bunch of video there
which were going to show our television
audience and this was a supposedly
nonpartisan March but there was a ton of
anti-trump stuff and it was sort of to
be expected and and there were people
criticizing this March by saying well
this is going to make science look
partisan or political because there's
going to be this undertone of anti-trump
rhetoric but the problem is that science
has been made a partisan issue and this
is evidenced by all the anti science
policy and sentiment by Donald Trump in
the Republican Party the point of these
marches was sort of to support science
and evidence based research and the
context is you have an administration in
the Trump White House that's cutting
budgets to science agencies removing
climate change data telling NASA that
they can no longer do climate research
the list goes on and on and what's most
upsetting to me is that we even need a
March for science this is 2017 this is
not you know I don't know whatever year
you want to point to in the past and we
still have a significant portion of our
country of the planet - but we're
talking about the u.s. right now that
resists science that believe science is
something you can have faith in just
like religion and this is one of the
most disturbing and problematic beliefs
that's out there I kept reading this
comment Pat from many on the right about
the Marches
protestors saying oh listen or rather
those who are criticizing the protesters
saying the people marching science is
their religion it could be just as wrong
as to say well Christianity or Islam or
Judaism is a fate requires faith and is
a religion science is their religion and
they have faith in science
this needs to be called out and
everybody who's watching or listening to
this needs to know how to react to that
faith in science is a fundamentally
bogus criticism I have faith in Jesus as
the Son of God is not the same as faith
in the scientific method and I think the
term faith should not even be used in
that sense they are not even remotely
equivalent and first of all what is
faith
right I mean faith is believing
something despite not having evidence
for it because if there was evidence for
it you wouldn't need faith there is
nothing in science and the scientific
method that is like faith it's the
opposite science has this process Pat of
checks and balances
whereas faith doesn't scientific
assertions are all tentatively true
based on the evidence we have until the
built in corrective mechanism of science
points in another direction when's the
last time Pat that you heard someone say
I have faith that Jesus is the Son of
God and was born to a virgin but that's
a tentative belief until something comes
along in points in another direction and
the whole idea behind religion is that
it's static and unchanging how the holy
books were written centuries and
millennia ago yeah are the same as they
are now that's right the Word of God is
perfect and irrevocable and unchanging
and if you go to your clergy and you say
hey you know what I'm doubting my belief
in God what do they point to they tell
you to study the Bible this is what's
called a closed loop of belief there's
no external check or balance scientific
assertions are not only completely open
in terms of how they have to fit in with
everything else we know about the world
debunking or correcting scientific
assertions is not only possible but it's
welcomed when you have someone in the
scientific community correct a
previously held assertion the more
important that previous assertion was
the more notoriety that goes to the
people who correct the assertion that's
the opposite who's out there in the
religious community trying to figure out
a more accurate version of Noah's Ark
right and scientific facts are true
whether or not you believe in them or
with them right and it's not like this
was a protest about abortion rights or
gay rights the Second Amendment where
there's two sides to the argument you
can have a legitimate debate I mean this
is going on now we need to be pushing
back against the idea that science is a
system of faith just like religious
beliefs because they have nothing in
common we shouldn't even need something
like the March for science but we need
it and one area where this is hugely
damaging is what Pat said with regard to
climate change which science tells us is
real and is impacted by human activities
on earth Donald Trump talked about Earth
Day which coincided with the March for
science didn't even mention climate
change period I mean even George Bush
mentioned climate change quote from
Trump this is April 22nd as we observe
Earth Day I hope that our nation can
come together to give thanks for the
land we all love and call home it's
abundantly clear Trump has no idea what
Earth Day even is from that but that's
no surprise
just because you acknowledge climate
change also doesn't mean you have to do
X or Y in terms of policy there's a lot
of people on the right pad who just want
to negate human influence on the climate
because they believe if we accept human
influence on the climate that means we
have to specifically do X or Y
legislatively no you could accept the
signs and say I don't care right there
are plenty of libertarians I think who
would accept the science but say we
shouldn't take an active role and try to
mitigate those effects right that at
least is intellectually honest I mean
it's the wrong thing to do but you know
it's consistent in that least no doubt
there is no doubt about that and that is
part of why you see so many on the right
there's many on the right who don't
genuinely in their heart of hearts
disbelieve the science on climate change
but they don't want to acknowledge it
because they believe that there's sort
of an obvious legislative path forward
and you know what they might be right
right I mean if we acknowledge what
we're doing to the climate most people
might agree about what it is that
governments should do to fix it
libertarians might not like it small
government conservatives or or big oil
might not like it but we can still
accept the science and then argue about
what the policy should be it's one of
those things where ignorant is bliss -
and I mean the topic of climate change
has really come around for decades yeah
this point and maybe at first the
science wasn't completely there so
people were skeptical at the time sure
and maybe they just don't want to come
around to it at this point
absolutely so yes the March for science
very successful
I am distraught about the fact that this
is even something that we need